they talk about trans people intersex
people that used to be referred to as
hermaphrodites which is a phrase that
that we don't
prefer anymore we find it to be very
triggering and offensive because of the
one that has been used historically
okay but it's always like that medically
i don't like the n-word right like
there's a certain
well not kind of like the n-word wasn't
hermaphrodite a medical term
welcome to another installment of there
are only two genders change
my mind unedited conversations with uh
people on the street usually we do this
on campus but during summer break that's
kind of hard to do
so before we start because this is a
long one i wanted to show you how this
conversation ends up
with our second person who who claimed
to be intersex
and got a little hostile and the reason
for this
is because of the length of these
conversations if you ever
feel like we're talking around in
circles or getting off in the details
you'll see that they come back later on
and they matter that's key when having a
conversation
and finding common ground so this is
about the end point
well no no no no no no no no the
biological makeup of a brain is not
societal the biological makeup of a
brain is right that's what i'm saying
right so what i'm saying the brain that
you call the male brain or the female
brain
you did not me i'm saying is closer to
that brain that that you were referring
to as a male brain
you referred to it that way so i want to
make sure i'm correct that you believe
there is a male brain generally
and a female brain generally when i'm
explaining my answer when i'm giving you
my answer
okay my answer is what you are referring
to as a male brain
is more i didn't you did that's why it's
important you brought this up male brain
and female brain i'm trying to
understand what you brought up i didn't
bring up male brain female brain
so that context matters because we are
going to rewind all the way to the
beginning
where you can see that intersex girl
works for this person who approached me
uh transgender male to female danielle
skidmore actually running for austin
city council
in district 9. how are you would you
would you like to to change my mind i'll
try okay
thank you very much i appreciate it
i've heard about your show so i thought
oh great thank you very much yeah right
appreciate it
what's your name danielle danielle
danielle absolutely so
uh stephen um and uh if you're familiar
at all with the show this is just where
we engage in civil discussion dialogue
and issues that are usually pretty
controversial they result in talking
points with a lot of people and
you know i can see full-length
conversations so i believe there are two
genders
okay you're welcome to change my mind
i think that uh i think human biology is
really complicated
and i think that gender identity is
real and intrinsic and i think that
i don't think there's a mindset sorry i
don't think there's a binary for
anything
you can ask are you transgender i am
actually
okay um
this morning and that's okay no that's
funny literally i was walking down the
street and i was like oh my gosh this is
a sign right there
right conversation so um
what what do you believe is is wrong i
guess about my state you said there's
two genders yeah
i think i've come to realize i'm trans
right yeah and uh
that uh why
why we are the way we are like what
makes our
core humanity right is
beautifully complicated so like my son
my son's got a genetic disorder right
he's missing an enzyme
that lets him metabolize two amino acids
right
why that is you have no idea like it
wasn't a biological variation sure right
it doesn't diminish
his humanity right but it is
fundamentally different
you know like why i'm trans to be honest
with you
i don't know right now it took me 37
years
to stop fighting what i knew to be true
from the earliest ages as a child
to work my way through the social stigma
of my reality which was that i know i'm
different
i don't understand why i am i don't know
why
i would you know go and hide in the
bathroom
or my sister's clothes right like when i
was
seven right like yet
it all got wrapped into the expectations
of society
okay so i want to make sure i'm just
kind of unwrapping this uh carefully
um you said the truth of your reality
yeah that you are a woman a transgender
woman
okay um how do you know that's the truth
how do i know that it's true yeah how do
you know that you're a heterosexual i
presume
heterosexual cisgender man okay it's
presumptuous
right no well that's okay that was that
was presumptuous but correct
okay uh well i think this is obviously a
big component to lgbtqai
community that uh preferences sexuality
preferences as far as i'm attracted to
women that's that's a that's a
preference obviously so
uh it's in eight i was born i like women
and uh biological i was born a male
because uh
i have a penis in the hormonal profile
and chromosomes of a male
so that's why i know that it's true to
state that i'm a male that you're
the male because you're you're a male
because like you're ex-wife
i didn't simplify to xy a multitude of
factors i have a male brain
i have a male body everything from bone
density to my hormonal profile
to yes my penis all of these things
pretty clearly
uh would file me in the cabinet under
mail biologically like in the spec
in like the spectrum of biological
variation you're in that big collection
of people that
have all of those things in alignment
yeah depending on the
interactive people right like
two-thirds of one percent is the best
number now right that um
are transgender based on you know what
we know
of that which in texas is like 130 000
adults right
who uh for reasons that are still
unknown are don't have
all of those biological components that
you described
don't align as cleanly as yours do
okay um well you say you know unknown
um again this goes back to you said your
truth that you are a female
you asked me why am i a male i i hope
that i've answered it as clearly as i
can
right so i would return that same
question to you because i think we need
to start with the presupposition there
needs to be the same amount of validity
to our arguments
as far as us rationalizing them you said
the truth
that you are a female you were born a
male
how do you know that's the truth i was
born a transgender woman
okay and how do you know that's the
truth how do i know that's the truth
uh like
in what biological context is it like is
it validated is that the question
yeah how how do you know that you're not
uh simply a man who believes he's a
woman how do you
like why do you so why are you if you're
heterosexual why are you attracted to
women
well there's a lot of biological
mechanisms in there namely to procreate
uh since the beginning of civilization
is attractive
sex attractive
i'm a gay man do you believe that that's
not their intrinsic reality
well again it's a sexual preference and
i think that's very important because
the sexual preference is different from
uh biology right and this is what i find
also pretty
interesting to me is right now they're
teaching that you know obviously you're
born gay
uh but gender is a choice
and that to me i don't i don't i don't i
just don't agree with so which one how
do you know you
you say that you're transgender you were
born a transgender woman right but i
would assume on your birth certificate
it said male
right so at some point you made the
decision to
live the way that you live right now
correct it's something yeah at some
point i made the decision
um it was almost a decade ago to
to unpack all of the guilt and shame i
felt for being different
right and at some point i made the
decision to
to unpeel guilt and shame right about my
truth
and to start trying to reconcile it with
the rest of my life and to reconcile
with a
society that is still
[Music]
pretty hostile to people who are
different so
it was a question of no longer fighting
fighting against myself yeah so and then
even after i did that i spent
another six years desperately trying to
not to not accept that
he accepted the truth and i'm like how
do i reconcile with that i'm an engineer
a civil engineer i'm a parent
congratulations
right like how can i how can i be who i
knew i
am and still function in society so
it took me years and eventually i
realized that i don't have a choice
like you know we look at the news this
morning right and
uh with tony borndane you know taking
his life right
right so 40 percent of
transgender people attempt suicide can i
pause you right there really quickly
just first off i hope that i haven't
been hostile i know you're talking about
you've been hospitalized
even this is a great okay good um
because i know we disagree but i
certainly don't want to be disrespectful
to you personally even if i disagree
with you
yeah i don't know that i don't find that
we disagree actually okay okay well i'm
glad that uh i'm glad that way because
the last thing i want is for you to feel
as though you've been sat down and it's
uh it's been a you know
sandbagging um and and you've brought up
you know anthony bourdain you brought up
the suicide rate i think that's very uh
important you know
it's about 41 it doesn't get better
after
uh hormone replacement therapy or even
actually doing the
full sex reassignment surgery so here we
are right i will
disagree with you okay i uh i think the
data shows
that when people are able to live their
lives as themselves
and are accepted in their community in
their social networks that's their
friends and their family professionally
in their city
when they're not stigmatized when they
don't lose their job when they don't
lose their housing when they aren't
ostracized or demonized right
like our state legislature spent the
best last spring and then called a
special session
essentially to demonize my existence
based on somebody's
you know i i don't honestly sincerely
held religious belief i'm not sure why
but to basically challenge my very
validity as a human being
right then yeah people can be frustrated
and scared and terrified and hopeless
and then kill themselves
but in my community when people are able
to live their lives and are accepted and
able to
you know aren't discriminated right then
their suicide rates fall
dramatically the single best thing you
can do for somebody who's lbgtq of any
sort but especially trans
is recognize their truth and accept
their humanity
well i would disagree with you there um
and first off i think you made a couple
yeah let me explain why you made a
couple of presumptions maybe they're not
uh
trying to uh demonize your very
existence maybe they just disagree with
you maybe it doesn't come from a
christian perspective maybe it comes
from a scientific one
maybe it comes from a perspective of a
medical perspective for example at
johns hopkins oh no that's okay i think
we're okay having a conversation you and
i right now right
yeah we're good we're good thank you
though um and the suicide rate
statistically anecdotally i'm glad to
hear
that that that your your group of
friends do better because one thing i
definitely don't want people
attempting suicide in a 41 percent not
just my friends i mean the data from the
national center for trans equality the
equality texas
hrc it's not it's not like my anecdotal
sort of
group of friends the scientific data
shows that when people are not
discriminated against and
transgender individuals who are able to
live their life whether
they you know just transition socially
or have hormone replacement therapy or
surgery whatever when people are able to
live their lives
their mental health is better
well statistically it's it's an accurate
statistically the suicide rate doesn't
really improve after
i you know sex reassignment therapy but
so maybe that's something we can follow
okay let's assume it's comparable let's
assume it's slightly lower let's let's
go with that i've seen the studies that
you're talking about and it might be
slightly lower it's not dramatically
lower
but i think this is predicated on the
idea and i don't think it's an
ill-founded idea
that because of discrimination because
of societal pressure because of feeling
like an
outsider uh people have more mental
health issues people are more prone to
depression people are more likely to
attempt suicide if they feel ostracized
and isolated
right yeah if they're treated as less
than human i would i would agree
um but the fact is minorities generally
commit suicide or attempt it
far fewer numbers for example white
males are two times more likely than
black men
the transgender attempted suicide rate
is higher than american slaves or jews
in concentration camps
are we to believe that um they have
they've been treated
more poorly in modern america than
american slaves or jews and
you're asking me to joshua you're asking
me to compare trans
of transgender individuals
to uh know the statistics the
statistical reality that nowhere else do
you find that suicide rate outside of
some serious psychiatric disorders
including those who have been enslaved
which might suggest again that this is a
this is a
not a truth as you said um people may
perceive it as a reality but
it may not be um it may not be ideal to
treat it just telling people that
that's the truth that's a reality when
it's in conflict with biology and their
hormones and their
brain and their biological makeup
because it can have catastrophic results
and how many genders are there because
now we're talking about non-binary right
i know
genders are there i don't i think gender
is a continuum
i think part of our so like this is my
take on it right and this is my
own personal opinion and how i've come
out how do you identify just so i make
sure
you sign up as a woman transgender woman
so you say transgender
woman but like you know i'm comfortable
owning the fact that i'm trans
i don't know that any of us has a
responsibility to own
anything about our own individuality
like i don't think
you anybody needs to walk down the
street and say hi i am a heterosexual
man or i
am a homosexual woman right like i
but for me i'm comfortable being visible
right
sure i'm lucky that i get to live in
austin and i get to be visible
and not suffer too many consequences
now the reality is i am a very small
sliver of
the trans population right i weren't
quite a professional right
my murder rate if i were an
african-american transgender gentleman
i'd be 30 times more likely to be
murdered than i am
so african-american men are much more
likely to be murdered than white men too
so a big part of that is right not
necessarily true this is real right and
that's that's
by other black people
race is a component of every all of our
interactions in
society
our gender identity who we are in our
brain from birth
before before we're talking about any
kind of hormonal replacement okay
yeah is varies across all of us
that i like i'm at peace with i honestly
think the science will prove
that fact there was a study that was
presented
this summer in uh i forget the
researchers i think we're belgian or
dutch and it was presented in
spain barcelona like a month ago that
doing imagery studying right so
functional mris
on brains of transgender children before
hrt okay so this is there have been some
studies that have done and the most
famous study was the remedy study what's
the
uh was done with folks who might have
been in transition or post-transition
yeah and this study has been
children who identify you know yeah at a
young age pre-puberty many
before any kind of medical intervention
and
studies are showing changes in
differences in brain structure
that are independent of whether somebody
is
sort of estrogen dominated or
testosterone dominant could you um
describe brain changes what do you mean
by that i'd describe you mean what the
studies were showing
yeah i don't know because i haven't
actually read the medical
like the bible the paper itself i read
the abstract or the information
i just want to make sure i'm understood
because we just jumped around a bit i
want to make sure i'm understanding what
you're saying so
they're you're saying there's a more
recent study that showed
children pre-transition transition uh
let's say a boy
who identified as a girl actually had
brain
differentiations from the standard male
brain yeah deviation so a transgender
girl
right her brain has structures that
they're observing with imagery now
that are more consistent with cisgender
girl
okay than they are with a cisgender void
okay
regardless of chromosomes regardless of
external genitalia
um i haven't read this recent study i'm
very familiar with the rometty study
and then the more comprehensive study
afterward which which said that the
changes only occur
after hormones are administered but um
it is interesting that you bring it up
so that would
that would presuppose then that there is
a male brain and a female brain
yeah right i i think there is a male
brain in the femoral brain
okay so then that would sort of uh that
would have to
dispel the idea that gender is a social
expression because you said it's a
spectrum but if there is a male and a
female brain
so that's a good point right then how
can someone be born with a male brain as
a female as humans
i think i think our gender identity okay
is real and intrinsic
and based in biology like that's
something that took me
four decades to really to work through
sure because of everything else socially
around us the
pressures for conformality you know
conforming and because
quite honestly being trans isn't easy oh
i can't imagine yeah
right so uh but and all of my
friends everybody that i like when i
finally came out and started coming out
and i have building with huge trans
community
circle of trans friends universally
like when we talk to each other we all
have the same lived experiences
that we knew this from a very early age
and what we struggle with is how do we
reconcile that with the rest of society
so yes
i think gender is real and intrinsic is
so
do you believe there's a male brain in a
female brain i think that they're all of
our brains
very beautifully so and i think that
there are brains that are
well early male or female i think
they're our brains when we talk about
somebody who might be gender non-binary
who are somewhere in between i just
they are i don't think that there's a
binary for anything but your point about
this so how many genders are there
how many genders are there because you
talked about demonizing people
and i don't want to demonize anybody i
don't want
no sorry yeah it gets a little noisy
last guy was going out with a harley
ah there's a yeah it's rat rally this
weekend oh is it okay um
so what was i talking about sir before
that truck
oh yeah i don't want any genders i don't
want to demonize anybody and of course
when you're looking at uh
uh state laws that misgendering could be
considered some form of assault or
misgendering could be hate speech
it's important if you're presenting this
argument as your truth somebody
proposing legislation
yeah it exists in canada already
misgendering is already is already a
crime and it's been proposed here in the
united states and so it's very important
that if we do that
okay let me just clarify okay i because
i spent a lot of time with the capitol
right last year
and i don't know i hope i don't have to
spend a lot of time next year at the
capitol but i sense
all of us feel the same way i know right
now about other things it's not exactly
a party but i don't see
uh i i haven't seen anybody proposing
that
uh somebody uh using the wrong pronouns
oh yeah so it happens all over the place
for example in new york if you're a
landlord and you do it you can be sued
um and in canada jordan peterson is
someone i would i would really look up
an example where like i'm not going to
argue or disagree with you because i
don't like without the
so you wouldn't want any kind of laws
like that the misgender you wouldn't
want any pronoun laws or anything like
that
pronoun laws no i mean i i think good
okay community
right i think that we should have
protection
non-discrimination protection that's
afforded to you know
well then it has to be defined like any
other protected group so it's important
i mean you've talked about your truth
and you living within society
yeah i think the issue with people who
disagree with it first off the
biological basis
uh obviously the suicide rate there are
a lot of concerns but also
right now we're restructuring all of
society western society
to accommodate less than one percent of
the population how are we researching if
we're going to
i'm sorry if i'm just finished if we're
going to do i think it's important for
me to know
yeah if i need to use the right pronouns
and not be accused of demonizing someone
even accidentally
how many gen how many pronouns are there
how many genders are there
okay well let me let me push back okay i
think
if you if you make if you use the wrong
pronoun right
somebody if i said you know
you know that if i used she her for you
right sure i made a mistake right
that's a mistake right and if somebody i
think it would be a deliberate insult
you're not
this wouldn't be a mistake you looked at
me and assumed as you said male
heterosexual and that's fine i have no
at this point if i chose to use she but
yeah
like if i'm talking and i say
you know she instead of he or maybe
like like just that right get it wrong
and then somebody says hey you know
it's she right it's a term it would be
respectful
what if someone says z what if someone
has a different gender that's not in the
binary and wants a new pronoun
and what if i won't be compelled to use
their language write some languages
how many genders are there how many
genders how many pronouns are there
what do we do with people who don't use
a property we treat everybody with
respect right
so if you came to me and said i would
prefer that you use
they them right because i'm non-binary
or z-zero okay
which is like a new term yeah which is
actually an old term
zero is older than they them right and
linguists will
like debate you know which is more
linguistically correct and and i
think that you know language is is an
attempt
to describe our society so
if you asked me to use they them yeah i
would
i would work to you say them because i
want to respect you right
but what if i inadvertently said he
right instead i wouldn't consider
that hate speech right well for example
i asked you if you were transgender when
you sat down yeah
i've asked people that who were
transgender and they were immediately
very offended
yeah um but again i have to know so that
i don't miss
misgender you so that i don't get into
trouble this this is a society
it divides us more than it unites us and
i tried to ask in a respectful way with
that but i don't think it divides them
well you should have seen this
lady in uh ann arbor she wasn't happy
about it wasn't happy that you asked
yeah translation i think it's a very
personal question right i don't think
it's very
if we go back to how many genders are
there how many pronouns are there if
we're going to restructure society i
think we need to know yeah but let's go
back to why
why does my gender identity
like in normal moving about society
right
why this whether i'm trans or not matter
to you
yeah well because it's a central
building block for society the american
family we see statistically that
children do better with a mother and a
father in the household it's the biggest
determining factor
all right it's the biggest determining
factor in poverty crime whether they go
on to college whether they
end up in prison whether they have a
family of their own happiness
mental illness mom and dad and his dad
specifically still in the household
i mean we talk about these social crop
programs welfare we talk about improving
education
if we could have more families with a
mother and a father with the children
there would be nothing that could affect
uh the productivity and the outcome for
children yeah
am i a lesser parent to my son because
i'm trans
i i believe that you're i believe that
all children blanket statement
do better with a mother and a father in
the household
what about that family arrangement is
intrinsically better than a mother
and another mother or two fathers or
a fair father and a transgender mother
it's a fair question
i believe that what about it is what
about it is better other than
it's it's not the majority right but how
is that intrinsically better
right um well the reason the statistics
reflect that as far as productivity and
outcomes with children is because
and in my opinion so that these are the
statistics my opinion and again you have
a lot of sociologists and scientists who
look at this
uh i think it's pretty straightforward i
don't i don't believe that two mothers
can provide everything that a mother and
a father can provide a child
and i don't believe that two fathers can
provide everything that a mother and a
father can provide a child
i don't believe men and women are
interchangeable but i think that's the
core issue
right now okay when we say gender is
non-binary that's a spectrum and we
haven't gotten definitive answers on any
of this
we're saying that gender is interesting
i think we do
i think we do yeah i i don't know that
we do
i don't like in my life when i'm moving
about the world right when i'm
practicing as an
engineer taking care of my son like
what my chromosomes look like is not
it has nothing to do with how i'm able
to interact with society
and how i'm able to take care of him i
think it has a lot to do with well i
like i'll tell you my lived experience
is that i am
just as capable of taking care of my son
now
as i was before and in many ways better
because i'm no longer fighting with the
crushing burden of knowing something to
be true
right and not being able to live it so
then when you talk about
people in a family that is a you know a
mother and a father being somehow
healthier for children
um i i come back to so much of the
health in our families and in our lives
has to do with everything else in our
social stigma that we're living with
so yeah you know something my reality
now uh
uh living in your world keep saying my
reality
my truth my truth what's the reality the
true thing is what matters to find
common ground
the truth
what's the truth biologically what's the
truth science
that's true biologically and all
creatures are phenomenally complicated
and the truth biologically is different
for every one of us
peter's truth biologically sure is is
different but it doesn't make him any
less human no it doesn't make him any
less human so there is no truth
just like just like an eight-week-old
fetus is no less human than a baby and
that's why i'm pro-life
this is human dna this is a genetic code
that determines
the idea so so no i don't think that
anyone is less human just like i don't
think so listen i have family members
who are bipolar right
right i've had i've had suicides in the
family i'm saying is that my truth is
i'm not really able to say a whole lot
you i haven't really gotten many words
in i haven't really able to express my
opinion but i'd like continue
well i wanted luck and then i think my
truth and that truth
is the question that i'm trying to
figure out is that what i hear from you
when you keep saying what is the truth
is that there is one singular answer for
what it means to be
human or what it means to be male or
what it means to be female or
specifically discussing gender one
that for gender and what i'm saying is
there's not
there isn't there's there's never been
through history there's never been when
you look at literature
all the way back into the bible it
reflects
you know the historical record reflects
that their
our biology our humanity has always been
beautifully complicated so it's not this
is not
i don't disagree with that statement but
i do disagree with the idea that gender
is a spectrum
and that there's in a limitless amount i
just disagree with that yeah i know
there's lots of yeah i know i know
you do right what was your name again
danielle danielle thank you daniel i
appreciate you taking the time too it's
good
i hope i hope this has been productive
for you as well as
as myself i really do appreciate you
sitting down and having a civil dialogue
even if we disagree listen honestly
above civility
but i think you should have both can i
mx a request
yes actually is that
imagine a world where people were
debating
whether you were as legitimate in your
humanity
i'm not debating that you're legitimate
in your humanity and just as i'm not
debating that someone that
my relative who's bipolar legitimate
humanity i'm saying imagine a world
where you
are yeah but i'm not i i'm not
suggesting you i'm talking about our
society right now i think you're
misconstruing i think if someone says
there's two genders you think that's
demonization
i think that's another humanizing i'm
asking you to have to
go into your headspace sure imagine
navigating a world yeah
where people will come up and actually
challenge
your legitimacy yeah which i which i've
done my truth
right not true which i've done i'll
grant you that i've done yeah and
like imagine living in that space where
strangers sure can debate whether or not
you're as legitimate
that's all i ask it's not about
legitimate it's about the truth they're
debating as to whether or not
legitimacy and the truth so what's the
difference between this yeah well
there's well
there's a big difference when it's your
truth or my truth and we're talking
about legitimacy legitimacy would be
much more confident with
the truth so if someone says gender is
not a spectrum
yeah if someone says there are two
genders uh
and that uh the biological research
would back this up and that i don't
think it's productive to continue down
this trail certainly of a limitless
gender spectrum
that's not quite questioning your
legitimacy as a human
that is questioning the nature of the
condition the nature of how you identify
and why that is the case and the
ramifications
societally so then you're implying that
there's something wrong with me
i'm implying that i believe you're
incorrect
i believe you were born a male and i
still would would believe that you're a
male yeah i won't misgender you i don't
experience a world where people could
tell you that you're incorrect
oh that happens all the time yeah it's
it's it's not a good feeling but
this is an issue no i appreciate it
danielle thank you very much i think
a friend here would like to get in thank
you very much i appreciate you taking
the time
now enter as previously mentioned
danielle's intersex
employee you'll note a little different
tone this is a i have a
long line of ginger genetics what's your
name alicia alicia thank you alicia i i
noticed you were there for a long while
with your
your video camera i heard that you all
were doing this who's your boss
danielle where you were just oh danielle
nice yeah alicia yeah my name is alicia
alicia nice to meet you alicia i
appreciate it
and it's funny i heard that y'all were
doing this and i texted her and i was
like i'm on my way she's like oh girl
i'm already there i was like okay
okay so yeah kind of a double team
action not
in like on purpose but just kind of
accidentally and that was a weird
phrasing of that too but
anyway how so well so i actually wanted
to talk about the biological aspect that
you were
referring to well let me present my
premise first because it's important
that uh people
anyone who's here who wasn't here for
the previous conversation
um this is designed to be a discussion
that hopefully opens a civil dialogue i
believe in searching for the truth
i uh my presupposition is that there are
two genders and if you would like to
change my mind on that you're more than
welcome sure well
so i heard my boss talking a lot about a
spectrum
not just in terms of like gender
identity but also in terms of
really any biological trait right that
humans like humans exist on a spectrum
whether it's a racial spectrum like
they're people that are half of
something or whatever like
biologically we're all on a spectrum
some men can grow facial hair and some
can't like some of it's defined by
your chromosomes some of it's defined by
hormone levels some of it's like
we all i think you would not refute that
we all exist biologically on a spectrum
in terms of
our phenotypes right and how how we
there are certain certainly
differentiations between people for
example you can have a multitude of men
some are tall some are short some are
fat some are thin so my red hair brown
hair yeah
but they're all men yeah it's nice when
we can agree on something
well so in terms of that spectrum and
where i hope that like my existence can
shed some light for you i was actually
born intersex which means that like you
would never know this and
no one who's ever you know been with me
sexually would ever know this either
but i was actually born with xy
chromosomes and so instead of having a
uterus and ovaries i had internal testes
that were then removed from me by
doctors who come
from kind of your perspective and some
similar perspectives that we need to
normalize people to fit
these like society driven standards of
what a human
is or should look like but so for me my
question for you
is if i irrefutably was born intersex
like i can
that's okay you don't i'll just go ahead
and get my like right now yeah
thank you that's another thing this
whole birther thing right that's like
proving
birthday basic yeah the whole birthday
movement right like needing to show our
birth certificates like prove our
legitimacy
as humans i'm thinking back to trump and
obama and everything anyway that's not
where i was yeah
unrelated that was silly um so if
if it is irrefutably true that i was
born intersex and then actually
almost two percent of the world's
population so 150 million
individuals worldwide were born intersex
so normalized through surgeries or
otherwise
if we're born somewhere in between in
terms of our like biological traits
then how can it not also be true that we
might identify somewhere in between in
terms of our gender and how that
presents itself
like certain people are born for example
with breasts and a penis or
they might have ambiguous genitalia or
like me you know like i was born with
like
i hate that i have to sit here at a
table with you talking about my
genitalia i don't believe any human
should ever have to do that
you don't have to well the reason the
reason i am is because
there are people like you and you know
that are i was about to say with respect
but that don't respect
basic biology people's identities and
like
that was kind of my biggest argument
against the bathroom bill when i was
arguing with lois cold course
is like if you want to pass a
discriminatory piece of legislation at
least open a bio textbook first like
it's not hard like
right these are just like basic science
okay so a couple of things there
um first off i hope you don't feel as
like forced you to sit down here in any
way
you force me but the conversation and
the existence of it that's what forces
me because there are people
who like are so fed up with having to
legitimize their existence on a daily
basis
when you don't have to do that right
like
you you were born in a way where like no
one is challenging that and that's
something that i heard my boss talking
about too that's actually it's actually
not true i would but you know we don't
get into my personal history
okay um so you mentioned a couple of
things there i want to start with water
for
there isn't we we used to until we
realized it was a legal liability if
someone if maybe uh danielle can get you
a bottle of water because you know you
know unless you want someone saying that
i poisoned you when i would never do
that yeah i'm sure you can understand
um so you mentioned basic biology basic
biology textbook and then you
immediately followed up with how someone
identifies yeah
i think they're two separate issues now
i understand that you're intersex we've
talked about this with several
right so then what do you think in
relation to that yeah
so we've talked about intersex so
another thing i would
strongly disagree with uh statistically
you said two percent of the population
are interesting i said almost here i
believe it's one point seven
yeah i believe it's significantly lower
than that particularly in the western
civilization
much lower there's actually a dearth of
data though as well because what happens
is doctors will play god and make a
decision about
what biological sex a child should have
and so they perform a surgery
and sometimes their parents aren't even
made aware or like with foster children
right like the state makes these
decisions
so like so you would believe it's higher
than two percent have a printout of like
a biotech book with me
but i don't want to argue with you you
reference a biological textbook
irrefutable truths right we can talk
about your opinion right but like i
don't want to argue with you about
science
sure well you haven't stated any
refutable truth so let's get to what the
truth is
okay um so you believe it's higher than
two percent i said
1.7 and that's what you said because
doctors play god the number's likely
higher
oh yeah right exactly yeah and so and
because this is also like when data
started being collected right like sure
is after a lot of these decisions have
been made there are people that aren't
told by their parents or by doctors and
don't even know until maybe
they don't get their period or you know
something like that
like helps them realize that they've
been born different right
um so i want to make you believe it's
higher than two percent or you believe
the statistic you've used is
accurate because you just said
biological truth i want to make sure
that i cited
is as accurate as the information that
we have available right now
okay that information as i just
mentioned
is not necessarily fully comprehensive
sure so you believe it could be higher i
want to make it that are made by doctors
okay
i would say the statistic is
significantly lower from the literature
that uh that i've read
um but again let's remove intersects
from the table because we're talking
about transgender we're not generally
talking about intersex so intersex klein
fellows
or genetic anomalies but that was my
question yeah well let me answer it can
i answer your questions
and then why would their gender so so
biologically they're
am i going to be allowed to answer at
any point but i let me just clarify my
question because you said
i'm talking about intersex and you're
talking about transgender but for me
this is related because
if people are born in between like in
terms of physical
manifestation right sure so then why
should they have to choose i'm a male or
a female if they were not born
a male or a female like yeah that's my
question okay so i'm gonna go back to
answering your question yeah um all this
was was very imperative in answering
your question because you said
biological realities people need to read
a textbook and then you mentioned how
somebody expresses themselves how they
identify
there are two different issues i'd like
to address them separately if we can't
but they're because i agree
if we take away i'm just going to keep
talking as though you're polite here so
if we take
intersects and we take for example
we take for example intersex we take
klein felder's we take genetic anomalies
that are very outside of the norm
so for example um there are some people
we've talked about this earlier there
are some people who are born without
feet
there are some people who are born with
webbed hands there are some people who
are born with 12 fingers and toes
but if what we teach in biology class is
that human beings
have two arms two legs two feet ten
fingers and toes
we don't teach biology we don't identify
biology based on certain
uh uh very based on outsiders yeah we
don't that's not how we teach biology
that's not how that somehow documents
that's not how doctors treat biology so
let me go to your so i want to i want to
separate
what we were talking about they're
intersex and in a very small percentage
versus
transgenderism people who choose to
identify who aren't born that way
but because you keep pressuring me on
that left let's go to intersex let me
ask you this
were you among the statistical reality
where you had some very
distinct primary sex characteristics as
intersex because the vast majority of
people born intersex
are not lgbtqaip activists they're
people who are born with very clearly
identifying traits it's not just right
in between
the vast majority have micro penis and
large clitoris
internal testes and it's pretty easy to
identify so was that the case with you
yes i was identified at birth as being
intersex okay but
not everyone is because as i mentioned
it was it the case where you were
identified as a female pretty quickly
you had primary sex defining traits
in that of a female i was i was assigned
a female because of the
choice of of the doctor that worked on
me right
but like i was born in between so for me
like
a doctor made a choice that even though
i was born in between even though they
knew because of a
um what's the amniocentesis so they knew
before i was born
that i had xy chromosomes but because i
was born with a vagina
they knew that i was intersex but
because there's a doctor again who plays
god and makes a decision because it's
all what's going to go on the birth
certificate
i was assigned female at birth okay so
you didn't transition later on in life
no no no okay so my question again for
you is just i just because the
statistics would reflect that
the overwhelming majority of people born
intersex are not just born directly
between the two
there's a very clear delineation with
identifying sexual characteristics of
communities
that's so not true there's there's
there's terrorism there's no
it is true but um so moving on from the
intersex if we remove that i think that
you are i think that what you're saying
is is correct i would certainly separate
you
someone who is born a certain way that
you know more
about the science of my existence than i
do i'm not the literature is there and i
want to talk about our sides
agreeing or being able to have
productive conversations i think that
maybe that's a first step
in in y'all's camp is like not assuming
that you know better than everyone else
who've lived a certain experience
i don't just like i don't interrupt well
i'm sorry you're you're interrupting my
day
by questioning my existence and my
boss's existence so i'm i'm not going to
apologize for interrupting
i didn't question your existence i
haven't questioned your existence
and i haven't interrupted you and i
haven't said that i know more than you
only you have done that in this
conversation so right now we're at a
crossroads we want to continue with this
conversation in it to be civil
and to disagree he's being televised or
whatever
record it as a mind watching it so if we
remove intersex and
very small percentage of outliers let's
say it's the 1.7
i don't agree but we'll go with that now
we're
addressing the transgender issue that
gender is a spectrum so
yes um why how many genders are there
why do we go with that because it's very
separate from genetic anomalies of
intersex
right gender is a societal construct
so as my boss mentioned
there is a spectrum so some people
identify purely female
or purely male some people identify in
between you
you already talked about the different
pronouns that are available and
it's based on your
you're something intrinsic that you were
born with in your head so we've proven
for example that in terms of sexual
orientation that being gay is not a
disorder it's just like
a biological reality it's a human
condition right
and um and being transgender is the same
thing it's like
you're born there's actually studies
that have come out now that transgender
brains
more closely align with
the gender of the brain that they
identify with than the brain of how they
were born can i can i address that
sure i have a question there so you said
so i want to make sure i'm not uh
misrepresenting your future you said
gender is a societal construct those are
your words
it is yeah okay so if gender is a
societal construct
how can there be a male brain in a
female brain as you just described
because they're there are brains that
fit like more if we're thinking about a
spectrum right like there's
brains that fall here on the spectrum
brains that fall here on the spectrum
like each brain biologically is
different like we know this because of
genetic variants and so some people
identify more with traits that we
categorize as female
and and so those brains look more
similar to those
who that i'm sorry but what you're
taking
you said it's a societal construct now
you're making a biological argument is
there biologically a male brain and a
female brain that are different
there is biologically a brain that is
closer to
a binary example of how people identify
people who identify as male
and and and present that way their brain
looks more similar
and so even if they have been born with
a body that
based on what we talk about in society
or you know
phenotypically like having certain like
genitalia or
you know gonads that like that we would
say are female
their brain still looks more
biologically similar like when doing a
brain scan
to someone who identifies as male
like there are certain types of brain
that exist on that spectrum can you can
you see how for me that's that's uh
not a super clear answer i want to make
sure that i don't get your
presupposition incorrect
there are generally male brains i do a
lot of generally
you know that like getting people to
repeat the same no it's not none of this
will be looking for like an outlier that
you can then cut and splice into
something but none of this will be
happy to answer another question if you
like none of this will be edited okay
none of it
all of us from beginning to end if this
goes up if this interview we don't put
up an interview
that is edited so i want to make sure
that i understand your
your point of view here there are what
is they're generally considered a male
brain
biologically and there is generally what
is considered a female brain
biologically
right by how we use gender fine male and
female but they're just like
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no the biological makeup of
a brain is not societal the biological
makeup
right so what i'm saying the brain that
you call the male brain or the female
brain with what
you did not me i'm saying is closer to
that brain that that you are referring
to as a male brain
you referred to it that way so i want to
make sure i'm correct that you believe
there is a male brain
generally and a female brain generally
when i'm explaining my answer when i'm
giving you my answer
okay my answer is what you are referring
to as a male brain
is more but i didn't you did that's why
it's important you brought this up male
brain and female brain i'm trying to
understand what you brought up
i didn't bring out male brain females
brain what what
society is referring to as a male brain
whether that person was born regardless
of their genitalia and their physical
presentation to the world
their brains are more similar in certain
ways
and that is because there's a spectrum
of types of brains and so there's a
brain that's like that and then there's
a brain that's slightly
to the right on the spectrum and then
one that's slightly to the right of that
and
and there's this whole spectrum of types
of brains just as there is a spectrum of
types of
skin color or facial hair all these
different things that we've talked about
right like
and so what we have found is there is
actually a correlation between
this identity and a brain that looks a
certain way so people aren't making
something up
it's like something that intrinsically
that they are born
feeling and identifying in this way
feeling and identifying in a way okay
and this is important because the
biology and the identification are two
very different things
so i'm going to continue along the
premise which you originally expressed
there is
i certainly agree with biology there is
a biologically defined male brain and
female brain they're different
they operate differently there are
different developments in different
portions of the brain
they fire differently they have
different levels of neurotransmitters
and they respond to stimuli differently
there's a male brain and a female brain
absolutely there are some anomalies
between there are some
very uh very a very huge number of
outliers in between but not much
there's a male brain and a female brain
okay but the entire world exists on a
spectrum
and then there are limitless genders and
limitless brains how do you determine
what's right with the literature how do
you run a scientific study if you're
saying there's a limitless number of
brain types
and a limitless number of identification
types how do you line that up as a study
if myself does not threaten your daily
existence
then why do you care it does it does
nothing from my existence
i believe the restructuring of western
civilization based on i don't believe
gender is fundamentally interchangeable
i don't believe men and women western
civilization is right is what you're
saying because they're
that's a different conversation but yes
really yes
so the whole white supremacist and
western perception of society is what is
i don't believe white supremacy is right
at all well western civilization
is arguably founded by the colonization
by white people
of people of color that existed already
now western civilization is not found in
the world
white supremacy at all so i believe
western civilization a civilization that
allows people to live freely the
civilization that freed slaves the
civilization that brought you that
iphone
technology paved roads plumbing uh the
romans did that earlier on but it was
very primitive yeah i believe western
civilization is right
and a fundamental role in western
civilization is that of male and female
and i believe that that is
very important as it relates to what we
teach children very important
as to how we rear children very
important as to how we jail people
if we're going to define pronouns we're
going to define gender identification i
think it's important if we're going to
change the entire fabric
the makeup to identify what it is so
with that how many genders are there
you'll have to
excuse me that i'm having trouble
engaging with someone who feels that
western civilization is the right way
which is founded in these certain
principles that i just mentioned
it's not the only way and that america
first mentality is actually what's
causing the degradation and like our
falling
of our status in the world is american
exceptionalism
really or your exceptionalism of your
viewpoint
if you really change your mind is not
open
to other ways of thinking let's here's
one thing if you're looking to change
somebody's mind coming in very
aggressive and interrupting
i'm angry i'm not but that's not a good
way to change somebody's mind
i you ask me a question and then i try
to answer and then you stop me halfway
through and ask me a different question
or tell me that i'm not responding to
your question so forgive me if i'm
frustrated
yeah well i i'm just trying to get clear
answers to understand your
presupposition
and then you you were the one who
brought up for example male brain female
brain and said no brains exist on the
spectrum let me let me bring this up
this is a very new thing you know the
modern gender theory
the gender non-binary where does it stem
from it doesn't
that's not the question again you're
asking no i'm asking you because you
said it's not a new thing i'm saying it
is it's not a new thing
okay so where does the greek roman
mythology there's all different types of
humans if you look at hinduism or
certain religions outside of your white
i imagine you're christian correct
yeah right outside of that societal and
worldview
there are a lot of different texts that
are very very old
that talk about all different types of
people that talk about
trans people intersex people that used
to be referred to as hermaphrodites
which is a phrase that that we don't
prefer anymore we find it to be very
triggering and offensive because of the
one that has been used historically okay
but it's always like that
medically i don't like the n-word right
like there's a certain well not kind of
like the n-word wasn't hermaphrodite a
medical term
no now the medical term is intersex
because the medical community
understands that certain phrases then
are used to marginalize other human
beings and so people
was it a medical term and so people
stopped using that was it a medical term
um so medically there also used to be
something called phrenology which was
measuring like the heads of black people
and saying that they were like um
scientifically less than others
all the time you're asking if it was a
medical team yeah they're also it wasn't
it wasn't like chronology well you're
considered to be very racist and bigoted
and outdated and marginal the reason i
bring it up things that
kind and open-minded humans do not use
sure that is my response to your
question well the reason i bring it up
is because
you brought up uh hermaphrodite and
compared to the n word was the n word
ever a medical term
you know i i don't and the reason this
matters again is yesterday's medical
term is today's hate speech
society can't keep up and that's why
definitions matter that's why gender
matters that's why biological studies
matter
like it's so hard for those people and
not the people who are being
marginalized
yes i believe it's important i believe
it's important for both people to be in
a society
i really do thank you very much i
appreciate it i'm sorry i don't have a
box of tips so let me give you
let me give you uh real quick simone de
beauvoir in 1949 that's where modern
gender theory started
then it goes to judith butler in the 80s
and 90s
hey there youtube viewer you like
samantha be of course not because you've
actually made it to this end
card you are a miracle of the internet i
would say subscribe or hit the
notification button but i don't really
know what that means on youtube you
might not get notified anyway but you
can join up at loudcrater.com
mug club that's a mug with this
wonderful hand etched mug and you get to
watch not only clips but the full one
hour daily show
every single day that was redundant
because i said daily but every single
day but we're going to keep it anyway
because we shoot these end cards
a whole lot in one afternoon
we're straight from the bottom of the
barrel with this one